forgiving hopeful entrepreneurs the cold
hard truth that he these shark tank I
love the show joining us right now Kevin
O'Leary author of cold hard truth on men
women and money Kevin welcome when you
joined Shark Tank did you think you were
joining a hit like this no no idea we're
so proud of the show because what's
happened in last few years is a lot of
kids are watching it these are people
that want to become loved Norris yeah
and that's a huge surprise for us who
thought business would be so interesting
to families and that's what's happened
it's a huge hit with families and we
love that we love it I mean I feel like
my heart rate goes up during the show I
just want some of the you know people to
get a deal gone
you mentioned kids what about financial
literacy when do you start talking akid
about money well that's what I'm really
focusing on now that's is one of my
causes is yours because I don't think we
should be concerned anymore about
keeping a taboo I think we should start
talking to kids at the ages 5 to 6
explaining where money fits in the
family why you have to understand where
it comes from what debt is these are all
the things that we don't do we teach
them education and everything geography
sex education physics math not money
that's crazy it is crazy number one
reason people break up who are married
money yeah what's the biggest mistake
married people make they don't do due
diligence on each other before they
married they let the emotional aspect of
courtship reign when really they should
be checking each other out to make sure
that they both are compatible ok but
let's say they didn't do that but now
they're married do you know that over
half the marriages dissolve and it's 90
percent due to financial stress Wow so
this is something the the courtship
process has to involve money period if
you don't have an understanding of your
partner's financial past you don't marry
them Wow so this way you made your money
it's software you first companies over
$25,000 so you've got your a great story
that took risks you want to get some
phrases out that sir appear in your book
money sits with you at the table at
dinner every night what do you mean I
used that because with my own kids when
they were 6 and 7 years old I started
leaving an empty seat they're saying
that's money that's money sitting there
and they would say whose money and we
talked about it I know that sounds crazy
but it worked they understood that that
was a member of our family and needed to
be respected because in your life money
can be your most powerful ally or your
worst enemy that is true in a nation -
absolutely the great lesson well in his
book he's got
50 common money mistakes and how to fix
them check it out cold hard truth on men
women and money Kevin O'Leary thank you
very much look at this signed by the all
up there it's not my copy because I
didn't pay for it because buddy said
I'll leave it with you okay thank you